hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another impossible let's
play for today's challenge I will be
taking this electroshock game and
playing it by myself while I try to
complete don't let go for the oculus
rift it's gonna be great
alright let's do this it's gonna be fun
ah okay it works okay I'm ready to get
started let's do this oh why do I do
this to myself let's go hello
first shot go ah okay it didn't it
didn't do it the first time I president
Obie's my old friend still not sure if
your if your bees are flies that is
tingly
ah that's tickly oh my uncle flip is
already drifting upwards hello how are
you doing today okay oh it's worse on
the last hand I don't know why it's so
occurs on the left hand it's like I got
better contact on it or something again
okay okay
ah okay this is it ah I forgot about you
you get either oh oh hey hello Dino my
old friend it's good to see you again
how are you doing you want to go them
over and give me a big lick why don't
you lick this device down here and we
can really get the party started
whatever you can see my muscles
twitching over there
like that started as a fake like
sarcastic oh no oh never mind this is
absolutely the ridiculous cake
shaky okay it doesn't exactly hurt it
just was like ah my hand suddenly is
bazevich out of control well I oh hey
sorry it was in the middle of something
were you trying to interrupt me I didn't
mean to do that huh
scary enough for you oh no absolutely no
there's a giant spider behind this left
oh really
that's shocking yeah okay all right okay
my hands are like going numb I think I'm
getting used to it hi Oh spider where
are you at
yeah all right okay oh I'm trying not to
let go and good this creamy hello my
little spider friend you want don't
touch that hand yet could you get shot
ah hello hello help you guys can I hope
this is actually working because I've
never tried a recording setup like this
before and it's ah ah ha ha I hear I
feel I hear and feel God yo kicks ah
okay are you son of a [__] I know I've
played this before but you're a son of a
[__] going into my brain okay don't let
go all my fingers stop it stop it
why do I do this myself the worst part
is I have to do it to myself literally
my keyboard strictly for me come back
keyboard okay oh yeah you where's the
button we lost the button there we go
okay kkkk alright you're gonna do your
little sword dance and then I'm gonna
try to hold on for dear life because
I've almost let go my fingers are tired
ah hello I wonder if the battery's dying
cuz it's either my hands are getting
numb or the battery and the machine is
dying what kind of [__] am i oh yeah
I'm markiplier that explains everything
why it's like totally different
ah yes I know I know hi hey GOG it's
like totally different each owe you some
okay that's about you get out out of my
ear
I don't I turn the volume I will rather
that I had it before we got a surprise
rate okay tingly fingers okay oh I
wonder what that's all about
oh no hi you bastard
oh one more good magic okay okay all
right what I do for a living
ridiculous I get to do this for fun yay
oh my god okay so that was the
electroshock challenge I didn't like I
wanted to tone it back down from the
three point yeah I'm sweating so much
you could even see it like it's all
lower me but either way
Oh much fun it was like it wasn't it
wasn't painful I don't want people to
worry like oh no he's electrocuting
himself this is like a this is like a
teenagers game so it's not exactly a
deadly volt of electricity I just had it
and I wanted to play it so there you
have it that was don't let go and I
didn't let go I did it I did the
challenge so if you enjoyed this video
and you invite enjoy these impossible
Let's Plays leave a like down below and
write in the comments any other
challenge you want me to do
maybe not hot sauce but any other
I am so open go wild go crazy thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye